six foot eight 225 pounds out of Duke
University say hello to Jay hello look
at the pants on him when I saw Jay I
said he's like Captain Stubing like he
looks like if he would be on The Love
Boat he would greet you as you came onto
the Love Boat you look good you look
like red white and blue your patriotic
going to nursing school you need his
Steph Curry's shoes I got him good to
see you you too
great to see you as always how many
Final Fours I was one as a player my
senior year we went to the championship
game and then three as a graduate
assistant coach and so my three years of
if you want to call what I did coaching
all I did was get Coach K coffee in the
USA today but my three years we went to
the championship game every year do you
miss that I do
yeah I miss I miss going to the
championship game every year yeah I mean
I mean honestly the thing I miss most
about about sort of being in it was you
know you had skin in the game you know
how it isn't broadcasting you finish the
game and you go out and have a drink and
you know you know you don't care who
wins or loses it's been you know now
spent 20-some years that I've gone to
basketball game so I don't care who wins
or loses and that's not the way it was
when you were younger you know you you
you cared and you care deeply now I go
to a game I don't care who wins I told
people that I tell people that all the
time they say who you're rooting for and
I said just a great story because you
can tell a great story
over and over and over and you know
hence we have Loyola of Chicago in here
but trying to cat it we love to
categorize and say okay where would this
ranked in surprising national champs I
don't want to say biggest upsets because
that that would be demeaning what Loyola
did during the regular season but let's
say surprising national champs let's say
Loyola won this where would it rank in
your opinion I think it would be the
best story that we've ever had I think
it would since the tournament expanded
to 64 in 1985 I think this would be the
story you know if Butler had won in 2010
if Gordon Hayward hit that half-court
shot that would have been it but this is
the with sister Jean and all the things
that go around
this would be the best story and and I
think Loyola Chicago has the best chance
of any of the double-digit seeds to win
this thing just because they're not none
of the other teams have this crazy
physical advantage over them and and I
think that's a that's a big difference
like there's not a super athleticism
advantage or size advantage it's really
sort of physically a fair fight how long
did it take you to separate yourself
from Duke where you didn't care or you
cared less about what they did when
you're working to separate that I don't
know that it was that hard I think the
hard part was early early on and this is
in the 90s of your sort of give back
then it was just getting started now I
think he could term it it's been a
career but worrying about what people
will say about what you said and I let
go that a long time ago it's been it's
been well over a decade and a half that
I've given up caring what people I mean
I care what people think but I don't
worry about it and if you say something
somebody doesn't like you listen to
their complain about it and if it's
reasonable you deal with it if it's
right you you you deal with it if it's
reasonable you listen to it if it's not
if it's unreasonable you dismiss it as
Coach K criticized you a few times yeah
over the years yeah they're few things
you've said that he didn't like and he
said so and but I respect that like I
want if somebody you know if you say
something somebody doesn't like I want
to know that they don't like it and why
you know it's alright I'd rather not
have them talking behind your back upset
about it just just say what you think
and let's you know we can figure it out
it's not that hard can you tell this
story cuz people don't realize J got
drafted by the Dallas Mavericks and they
had guaranteed contracts so you weren't
gonna make the team you go to Italy and
then you meet up with Leo route ins who
was the great big man at Syracuse he was
your teammate in Italy and he tells the
story I'll let you tell it better but he
leo was a great you know good passing
big man good shooter the whole thing so
he wants to be a facilitator when you
get to Italy right that he's gonna be
the passer when you get there he's gonna
you're gonna get some shots yeah he was
more than a than a passing big man he
was a six eight point guard he played
point guard he actually he and Magic
Johnson he went to Minnesota before he
went
Turkey's and so Leo I think either led
the big ten and the sister was right
there with Magic Johnson and like 1979
but then he transferred and went to
Syracuse so I had met Serkis recruited
me I was actually shockingly the first
kid from California that Jim Boeheim
ever recruited and then he always says
that after he found out he could get a
kid out there he recruited the good
place but so I knew Leo from before we
were teammates in Italy so one of my one
of my teammates in Italy back then there
were only two Americans per team so a
guy got cut and then they brought Leo in
and so I'd known him and so we went to
dinner and Leo was telling me now you
know I'm a great passer you get open I
will get you the ball I promise you so
we play the next night and and he shot
it at he scored 40 points and shot it
every time he touched and and after the
game we won and after the game I was
like what happened to this great passer
thing and he said well I what I didn't
tell you was the first rule of a point
guard is understand the limitations of
your teammates did you last in Italy
three years it wasn't how long I lasted
I'm sorry my bad how did you how long
did you my shelf-life they discovered I
was a fraud in three years Dan I was two
years in Italy and then that played a
part of a year in Spain what's going on
with these Syracuse recruit who's you
can see got a five-star recruit he's
going to the G League here yeah Baisley
yes yeah he's out of Ohio yeah it's like
just about 18 I don't even think he's
turned 17 and left-handed kid 69 he's
really really talented player but what's
this mean if is he gonna be drafted and
then he goes to a team or did she just
sign with the G League team I don't know
how this G league rules are different so
you know it once your draft eligible you
can sign these two-way contracts which
some people confuses some people he goes
directly into the G League and he will
be drafted out of the G League when he
becomes draft eligible so he's not draft
eligible under the current rules until
he is he's one year removed from his
high school graduation and 19 years old
he can't play in the NBA no he cannot
play in the NBA until he's draft
eligible that sort of that okay that's
sort of the rule
through the collective bargaining
agreement as when you can be drafted and
he's gonna get
I think this salary is upwards of 26,000
that he's going to be able to make but
I'm curious is this is this a one and
done for him you know that a great high
school player is gonna go into the G
League or do you think this could open
the door where kids go you know what
maybe that makes more sense for me I
think unless you can get a bunch of shoe
money they're their endorsement
possibilities and in the instant overlay
doesn't do anything with this rice
Commission to open things up I could see
some more players doing it I can get an
agent yeah so I can somebody confront me
$75,000 or $100,000 legally yeah oh yeah
if you yeah if you go into the G yeah
yeah yeah
well and that's the thing about about
this whole FBI thing you know take a
shoe company shoe company can come to
you as a player out of high school
before you ever get to college and say
hey we'll give you half a million
dollars to bypass college there's
nothing illegal about that you could do
that in a heartbeat the only thing the
only thing illegal and I don't even
think it's illegal but but the
government does the only thing illegal
about this whole thing is is the the the
players the violation of NCAA rules is
putting these institutions in peril and
and they're the victims according to the
government's theory the school is the
victim because they could be they could
be losing money if they if they are
caught violating an c-double-a rules and
and you're like wait a minute that's
like a bank defrauding its customers and
saying look we're the victim because the
SEC could come in and and hit us with
sanctions it's crazy but this is a way
that you can avoid college get paid go
into now this is a worst-case scenario
for college basketball I would think I
think it I don't think it's the
worst-case scenario but I think it's bad
and here's why I have a different
opinion on this than most other people
are some people and that is I think
we're sending a really bad message to
young people that are coming up in the
game and that is we are we are basically
saying if you in the NCAA is saying it
if you don't want to come to college and
live by our arbitrary timetable of four
years in school to get a degree and play
play for us under our rules if you don't
want to be Bill Bradley
don't want you at all and I think that's
a really bad message to send to high
school kids and kids younger than that
in this game that are largely
african-american I think that's a really
because I think one year of college is
better than none and I think two years
better than one and I think establishing
a relationship with the school is a
really good thing for any kid and I
promise you there are people within the
n-c-double-a structure that say this all
the time I hear it they say some people
don't belong in college yeah and my
response to that is screw you we've got
thousands of colleges in this country
there is a college for everyone now your
school might not be for everyone but
there's a college for everyone here in
any n-c-double-a administrator that says
that my response to them is screw you
well see that's why he's known as the
moral compass here speaking on behalf of
America you are the compass here a red
white and blue we were also talking
before we came on the air you know Jay
played basketball in uh in California
Los Angeles and and you would play
pick-up games Cheryl Miller was Reggie
Miller's sister so you would actually
play in games where Cheryl was playing
yeah they were pickup games there were
real games when I was a kid and it only
happened once I played against her but I
played on a little travel team what's
she better than Reggie at any point I be
surprised maybe but I mean Reggie's
younger than her oh my god plenteous
Reggie in in high school Reggie it was a
great player how many do you score I
don't remember numbers but I mean even
back then before there was a three-point
shot he shot it from everywhere and to
the point where other players didn't
understand what he was doing is there's
no 3-point no three-point shot back then
this was this was the the early 80 and
and he could he could really shoot it
and there was no way he weighed 150
pounds or hundred say he was say six
seven hundred fifty yeah like he bulked
up at UCLA he walked by the weight room
and gained weight but if people don't
and we love to compare and I just did it
but you know we'd love to compare
women's basketball like how would Diana
Taurasi play against the men and I
always say you miss you're missing the
point of watching you know Serena
Williams well how would you do against
Roger Federer
enjoy what you see in the world that
they're in instead of saying well you
know Annika Sorenstam couldn't play on
the you know PGA Tour
okay maybe she couldn't but if she's
still great in what she does you look at
women's college basketball now you know
what UConn is doing is it great for the
game that UConn is dominating I don't
think it's any better or worse for the
game than UCLA was for the men's game
I think UConn is is phenomenal if you if
you look at all the other teams and the
rest of the landscape of women's college
basketball and I watch you know I'm not
telling you I watch it as much as men's
cuz I don't but I watch it there's ups
and downs for every other program so you
know Baylor has been great but they're
not you know they everybody has ups and
down marilyn you name it now all for
number one seeds maker but they're not
the same for number one seeds all the
time
UConn has been there consistently
forever and and the consistency with
which they play at the highest level is
shocking and they have very little you
know very little dips in any regard and
they compete I think their practices are
probably as competitive as any game they
ever play it's ridiculous how good well
that second team could be better than
most first teams exactly brothers you
know there's school exactly there it's
and Geno's as good a coach as there is
in any sport C as good as Coach K yeah
yes yeah because people say oh well you
know are you interested in coaching the
men I go he doesn't like TF now prove
that you can really coach by coaching
the men I go he doesn't have to do that
he doesn't have to but if he wanted to
he could do it in a heartbeat so good
Pat Summitt have done it do you think
that UConn looked at him to replace
Kevin ollie
yes they did yes so do you do that as
the obligatory hey are you interested in
this and if you are you want to have the
job oh no I think it well I think it was
very serious I think for them to - if
you've got a Hall of Famer down the
hallway yeah and if you're not looking
at me I think somebody needs to look at
your your position and see what are you
doing he was close was he interested in
doing it oh I have no idea okay I have
no idea whether he would have done it
whether he had interest in it but but
you know that that the decision-makers
were going wait a minute you know we
have this yeah we'd be crazy not to do
this right
during the commercial break a live
looking would you judge the Dennett's
jumpers
let me just form do you think there's
gonna be what do you think the decisions
gonna be there straight to the G League
[Laughter]
they might want to negotiate that 26
grand down a bit is there a Z Lee
gee-whiz League J great to see you
great to see you as always contributions
you know the entire year with college
basketball we appreciate it kind of
eases the moral compasses Jay Bilas for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]